Das St. Gotthard-Massiv war einmal
Haupthindernis zwischen Nord und Süd
von Europa kam der Berg in die Quere
Menschen und Dinge
auf dem Weg und musste gewonnen werden
mit großer Mühe heute die Passage
es geschieht auf einfachste Weise
Überqueren des Tunnels, der die schneidet
Berg, als ob das Tal in der gefunden
lebender Felsen seine Verlängerung a
null km
hier also der neue basistunnel
del san gottardo Stahlbetonkabel
Spuren und gelegentlich ein Ort zum und
Reaktion
während unserer gekreuzten und lit
zur Notbeleuchtung für
erlauben uns einen besseren Einblick
Auf diese Weise hebt es die Kartäuser hervor
Schweizer Präzision im Tunnel aber was
trotz allem erscheint es in gewisser Weise
wenig spektakulär eine Galerie nichts weiter
auch wenn nicht irgendein Tunnel da ist
Gotthard-Basistunnel ist heute
der längste Eisenbahntunnel der Welt
verbindet Rotterdam und Genua
zürich und mailand dank dem neuen
arterie ganz europa ist ja verdichtet
es nähert sich
Diese Leistung ist nicht jeder kostenlos
Tunnelmeter kostet über 200.000
Franken
nächste Station
se drum hier ist eine der vier
Nothaltestellen im Tunnel
ein Feuer ist ausgebrochen, ein anderes passiert
Alarm
hier können sich Passagiere sparen
Notdocks öffnen dann
sogar die grünen Fluchttüren, die sie geben
grünes Licht für die Röhre
Evakuierung neben einem der
diese Rohre
durch einen hohen und dunklen Kanal
der Belüftung kommen wir zum einzigen Punkt
offener Berg
keine Stahlbetonkapsel
Pflaster zum Abdecken der offenen Wunde des
san gottardo versammelt sich in einem kleinen see
das Wasser, das tropft aus dem fließt
Berg entlang einer Leiter gehen wir hinunter
zum Ufer einen Bauhelm
wahrscheinlich leichtsinnig vergessen
Oben im See schwimmt öffnet sich einer
dunkler Riss im Berg und Blätter
Stellen Sie sich die steinernen Massen vor, die belasten
am Gotthard-Basistunnel
für immer im Berg begraben
die 15,8 Millionen Franken bleiben übrig
wurden bereits für die beiden Zimmer investiert
Aspekt des Alpentors 800 Meter
unten, wenn die Drohne hätte aufsteigen sollen
in der Mitte des Tunnels
der tiefere Bahnhof an der
Welt, die als Bindeglied fungieren würde
mit dem alpinen Fremdenverkehrsort heute
nur zwei Tore im Berg versperrt
durch schwarze Eisenstangen und das Schild
verboten zu betreten noch daran erinnern
Traum löste sich in Luft auf
hinter Gittern in einer Nische siehst du
die statue von santa barbara ist ihr dort
Schutzpatron der Menschen von
Berg und Bergleute
unabhängig von ihrer Nationalität
und ihr religiöses Bekenntnis
Bergleute verehren ihren Patron a
flüchtiger Blick ein kurzes Dankeschön eins
Gebet
manchmal sogar gar nichts a
einmal im Jahr immer am 4. Dezember
Das Fest des Heiligen steht im Kalender
barbara
dabei geht die erinnerung nach
Opfer des Berges
Pfade 800 Meter entlang des Brunnens
tanken kamen wir in sedrun an
Jetzt können Sie die Flucht in die Fehde beginnen
das überdachte st.-gotthard-massiv
Schnee, was für ein verrücktes Panorama 2.300
Meter unter diesen Felsen verläuft
jeweils der tiefste Basistunnel
ein weiterer Tunnel der Welt und wenn du es bist
im Tunnel dieser Show
unglaublich natürlich von diesem majestätischen
Alpenmagie sieht nicht einmal den Schatten
wir überqueren nun die Grenze zwischen Graubünden
und der Kanton Tessin vor 1803 la
Die Schweiz endete hier, jetzt sind wir
offiziell im Süden
wir werden wieder verschluckt
Berg und wir lassen uns ins Dunkel fallen
Der nächste und letzte Halt macht es für mich
kinder idee flöte von pcb zone hoffen wir
dass diese Ankündigung niemals sein sollte
übertragen, wenn nicht zum Nachweis es sein kann
über das Audiosystem des hören
Tunnel
Dieses System funktioniert wurde getestet
Sie wurden von Ingenieuren gründlich getestet
anstatt immer das Gleiche zu passieren
Ankündigung, die die Ingenieure verbreiteten
Musik soll die Arbeiter nicht langweilen
und die Nerven nicht zu strapazieren
aber sie haben sich nicht irgendeine Musik ausgesucht
aber der letzte Satz der neunten
symphonie von beethoven leinen europa
km 57 die schneebedeckten Berge
wir haben sie uns überlassen
Schultern
der gotthard einmal main e
größte Hindernis des alten Kontinents
und heute nur noch ein Tunnel